[Music]
hi I'm Stuart brand from longer now okay
that's the individual perspective what's
the organizational perspective and how
many generations are there in the long
now so we say next ten thousand years
last ten thousand years the next ten
thousand years we don't know how
generations are going to be counted that
the last 10,000 years the
anthropological standard is every 25
years there's a new generation so that's
four hundred generations going back
imagine an organization that could have
representatives from all 400 it would be
pretty adroit managing in the long now a
lot of organizations is here in San
Francisco I have basically one
generation and most generations might
get to two and almost none to get to
three but how about what are the
advantages of getting to three some of
these experience that thought about it
written about it and now teaching about
it it's a master of hospitality and now
the master of intergeneration allottee
chip Connelly
Thank You Stuart
it is such an honor to be here tonight
thank you yes so this quote says a lot
and it's gonna have a lot to do with
what I'm going to talk about today so my
talk today it's the first time I'm
giving this talk so I yeah you're not
getting old Ted stuff you're getting
you're getting the new stuff and I have
my notes in my pocket here and I may
need to look at them at some point and
you're gonna learn a word that I learned
in the last few years which is liminal
I'm getting a liminal with you tonight
which means I'm in between two things I
have not really studied this talk
tonight but I know it I've lived it and
I'm gonna do my best to share it with
you so let's start with me and my dad
there we go that's me of my dad that was
less than a year ago we were in
Indonesia and a place called Seoul oh I
see we were going we were going scuba
diving my dad took up scuba scuba diving
at age 60 and has been all over the
world for the last 21 years he was 80 at
this time I was 57 at this time I'm 58
now and weirdly before we did our
early-morning scuba dive I went onto an
online longevity site - and throw it
through in all my information to see how
long I would live I don't know why I
chose that morning to do it but I put it
all in there and it spat back to me 98 I
mean live til 98 so I went down to get
prepared with my dad to go out scuba
diving and I said to my dad dad you know
how long you gonna live and right out of
his mouth immediately says 98 truly true
story
so I said that's so interesting dad dad
on the way down here I thought you know
when I was when I was on the site
tonight I heard this morning I found
that I was gonna be living till I aged
98 to maybe and I did the math as I was
coming down to go scuba diving with you
this morning I am less than halfway
through my adult life at age 57
I have 39 if I start counting at age 18
I have 39 adult years behind me I have
41 ahead of me I'm not even half at half
time at age 57 and dad at age 80 you're
barely in the third in the fourth
quarter so when we start thinking that
way we learn how to scuba dive later in
life I'm learning how to surf I started
learning how to surf a year or two ago
not good at it at all and as a kid who
grew up in Southern California who
learned French instead of Spanish that
was not smart but it did leave to the
name of my companies you wanna be but
that's about all it led to and my
Spanish isn't so good but I live in
Mexico a lot of times so I'm learning
Spanish and learning to surf and a lot
of things at an age in life where in the
past we thought your vision got a lot
more narrow your life got a lot more
narrow well it our perspective on time
and longevity has
a lot to do with this we've seen some
major changes over the last couple
hundred years in terms of how long we
live if you see between 1919 at 50 there
was at almost a 20-year increase in
longevity during that time and then
another 10 years in the latter part of
the of the century of the 19th of the
21st century I'm sorry the 20th century
so actually in one century we added
three three decades of life to the
average person in the United States from
age 47 to age 77 and so that actually
sort of led to a lot of things that we
still haven't figured out yet we're
still figuring this out because this all
happened so quickly
imagine life without adolescence
now if you've had kids that's probably
an interesting question but a hundred
fifteen years ago the word adolescence
did not exist until this guy G Stanley
Hall created a two-volume set with the
book named adolescence his premise was
and it had a huge impact on on society
at that time was that childhood actually
doesn't go to age just doesn't go to
till just puberty prior to that in some
ways we thought of childhood just being
a pre puberty thing and that's what
people in the teen years were actually
working with adults in industrial plants
so he said no actually adolescence or
puberty is this transitional time it's a
transitional time when your emotions are
changing your physical body's changing
and you're getting ready for the gifts
of Elder hood I'm a dolt hood excuse me
what if we took a page out of Ken Dyke
Wald's language from decades ago and
actually imagined midlife as not being
adolescents but middle essence which is
a word that's actually not well known
and what if middle essence midlife was a
period of life where you're going
through lots of emotional and physical
changes to prepare yourself for the
gifts of an elder hood
I'll talk a little bit more about that
the for those of you don't know it the
most popular most number one selling
poet in America today is Rumi yes 750
years after he died and this is a
beautiful quote and probably bees in the
room he's so popular he talked about
laughs a lot yeah people like that but
part of the reason he's so popular is
because a lot of things he said 750
years ago or he wrote address modern-day
issues he said my life can be summed up
in three phases I was raw I became
cooked and then I burned this defines
the three stage life of modern life so
you this is how we've been living for
the last century or so you learn till
you're 20 or 25 you earn - you're 65 and
then you retire till you die that sounds
awful it's really but it has defined in
many ways the societal narrative of our
phases of life
I think Rumi should come back seven or
50 lights later and just say I was raw I
became cooked and I burned and then
repeat raw cooked burn rock burn so
wouldn't that be interesting if we could
be raw again in our life like slow-mo
slow-mo became raw again in a whole
different way now a different sort of
interesting perspective on life stages
comes from Mary Catherine Bateson so for
those of you don't know Mary Katherine
basin she's the daughter of Margaret
Mead cultural anthropologist and Gregory
Bateson the psychologist
her point of view is our increased
longevity has not actually just added a
room at the back of our house almost if
you think of it that way
if you get this extra 10 or 15 years you
just added a master bedroom to the back
of the house but it's sort of like it's
almost like saying you just have 10 or
50
years of additional decrepitude and
old-age her point of view actually is no
that extra 10 or 15 years we may have
relative to our parents is actually a
midlife atrium and that midlife atrium
actually allows light and air and
sunlight for some reflection and renewal
throughout the whole house and so in
essence our extra 10 or 15 years may
mean we actually can be renewed in
midlife so we get those those extra
years not at 80 or 90 we get them at 40
or 50 and we have vitality a lot longer
well I wish I understood that blueprint
that architectural blueprint in my life
about ten years ago ten or eleven years
ago in 2008 my life fell apart in a
variety of different ways first of all I
had a very close friend of mine named
chip who is my insurance agent insurance
agent and one of my best friends who was
the person I would go to often when I
was feeling a little depressed he
committed suicide in 2008 and then four
other friends of mine over the next
three years committed suicide I had a
long-term relationship end though I
wasn't expecting I had a family member
in my life going to prison wrongfully
was in prison in San Quentin for eight
months until a federal judge let him out
I had a flatline experience giving a
speech on stage I promise I won't do it
today
I had a flatline experience where I was
giving a speech I had a broken ankle and
a bacterial infection in my leg and I
was on antibiotics and on crutches in
st. Louis now I know you'll ask the same
question my mom asked what the hell are
you doing you should have been in bed
yes I should have been but I went
flatline when I was signing books
fortunately I was sitting down at the
time and you know I came back but I went
flat lying nine times in 30 minutes all
of that happened at exactly the time the
Great Recession came along
and so and I was for those of you who
know me a little bit I started a
boutique hotel company called Yad Aviv
with the Phoenix in the Tenderloin which
which for those of you who used to know
it thirty-two years ago it used to be
called the Caravan lodge and it was a
no-tell Motel because it had hourly
rates how many of you knew it back then
come on out here some other they are
there right there okay
thank you yeah so I loved that job I
loved that calling of being the founder
and CEO of this company creating 52
boutique hotels over the course of 24
years but I loved it until I hated it
and and that great recession I was
hating it I didn't want to go through
the great recession like with invisible
handcuffs trying to run a company that I
that no longer had any creativity or
freedom for me so I didn't have that
architectural blueprint at age 47 at
that time I had no idea what I was going
through no one had told me what midlife
was supposed to be about I didn't know
about the idea that you know there which
I'll talk about in a few minutes that
there's a sort of a low point in life in
terms of the you curve of happiness I
was in it I didn't know I could come out
of it so one of my favorite pop culture
movies of the last few years was this
movie the intern with Robert De Niro
he said musicians don't retire they quit
when there's no more music left inside
of them well ultimately in the great
recession I was able to sell ah de vivre
which was not easy to sell a hotel
company you know in the depths of the
downturn I knew I needed to move on I
knew I had music inside of me but I had
no idea where to share it I had been
doing the same thing for 24 years and
then these three guys came along Bryan
who is standing on a box to make himself
a little bit you know I love Brian but
he's not a tall guy nate is a talk
and that's Jo as well so Brian called me
Brian Chesky called me almost exactly
six years ago it's so funny I was just
talking to Kevin Kelly here six years
ago I was at Maha khumba Mela in India
doing the largest humanity human
festival in the world and I came back
from it and Kevin just came back from it
I came back from it and immediately
three days after being back I had a
phone call from Brian Chesky at Airbnb
saying he wanted to talk to me about
Airbnb and how I could help them
democratize hospitality so I first said
to him what's Airbnb and he says well
you don't know whatever B&B is and I
said well I've heard of it all right
like aren't you like a subsidiary of
couchsurfing or something like that is
it no now we're a different company than
couchsurfing all uber over to your house
let's talk about it and I said to him
what's over true story six years ago I
did not have an uber or lyft app on my
phone so I had no quick never heard of
the sharing economy even I didn't know
what he was so Brian came over he told
me listen you're gonna be the head of
global hospitality & Strategy and you're
gonna help us take our little tech
startup and turn it into a global
hospitality giant all that sounded
really great except I was 52 years old I
had never worked in a tech company
before especially a company like Airbnb
where the average age of the employee
was exactly half of mine it was about 26
26 and a half I was the average age of
the employer there I didn't know
anything about tech at all I also was
gonna be reporting to Brian I was gonna
be his in-house mentor that was part of
the idea but I also would be on the
leadership team reporting to a guy 21
years younger than me after having been
CEO and Founder my own company for 24
years how was that gonna work what was
it going to feel like to get my first
performance review from somebody who's
the age of my son you know or my
theoretical son so
um so I I scratched my head and I
thought you know and by the way in terms
of that little fact 38% of us in the US
have a boss that's younger than us and
by their saying by the year 2025
over half of us will have a boss that's
younger than us
this is a big change there's a lot
happening so I said yes to Brian I said
sure let me help you democratize
hospitality that sounds like fun
and yeah I'm sure it'll be yeah not easy
and I joined and I even though I was
intimidated I knew this was not my
natural habitat I joined and then on my
third job I said okay I don't understand
tech at all so Brian said go sit in some
meetings with some engineers so I sat in
a meeting with a bunch of Engineers and
their dozen of them I got an average age
about 26 the guy running the meeting
found out was 25
he's basically a wizard he was so smart
and I'm sitting slightly away from the
table so I'm there in the room but
slightly away and and I think everybody
got the sense that I'm just observing so
and I'm making notes during the whole
meeting I make notes of everything I'm
hearing because I don't understand a lot
of words so all of a sudden the wizard
turned to me and he said chip if you
shipped a feature and no one used it did
it really ship
what I took philosophy in college I did
not take comma sigh I have no idea what
you're talking about
after a awkward silence I mercifully he
moved on to someone else and I slid down
at my chair and I couldn't wait for that
meeting to end and that's when I
realized I I was not the mentor I was
the intern now Robert De Niro was
brought in by ad Hathaway because she
wanted an intern and he became the
mentor my path was the opposite I was
brought in as the mentor and I became
the intern because I had no experience
knowledge or understanding of this new
brave new Home Sharing and tech world in
fact at one point at the end of my first
week I met this guy I met Joe Gebbia and
earlier and then I met Joe Bott who was
this they both of them sort of led that
the product team and Joe bot said he was
a head of product to me and I tried not
to grimace because I that didn't sound
right to me I went and looked for Brian
and I said there's this guy Joe bot and
he says he's the head of product I'm the
head of product I'm in charge of the
host the host and the homes in the
apartments right Brian like chip product
is the software applications to our
website oh okay I started to learn you
know the lingo was beyond me and all
these women were calling each other
dudes I didn't get it um so so I learned
pretty quickly
what inter gen improv is about now
intergenic think this is so interesting
we're into jazz and the jazz SF jazz
right now because inter gen improv has
been well known in the music world
I mean think of these two Lady Gaga and
Tony Bennett or Wynton Marsalis maybe on
this stage with the young stars of jazz
the idea of inter Jen improvin this this
sort of riffing off each other is what
we know in the music world for many many
years there's lots of examples I could
use but we don't know of it so much in
the working world and yet when it does
happen often it happen
in the form of almost like a mutual
mentorship we've no mentorship as when
the physics of wisdom goes from old to
young reverse mentorship which was
created about 20 years ago by Jack Walsh
at General Electric is when he but he
knew his senior executives didn't
understand computers or the Internet and
the young people at General Electric
actually helped teach them that was
reverse mentorship the future to my mind
is all about mutual mentorship where
it's actually I'm learning I'm learning
as much from Brian as he's learning from
me now my experience in my four years
full-time at Airbnb before the last two
years I've been a strategic adviser so
I've been at Airbnb now six years was
very much what you see in this picture
it was generally me a generation or most
often two generations older than most of
the people that surround me surrounded
me the mutual mentorship we often had
was and I hate the stereotype especially
with Kevin in the room because Kevin is
such a smart technologist and older than
me but it was an EQ for DQ implicit
Trade Agreement what do I mean by that
the thing that I had been brought in by
by Brian to do was he he thought I was
coming in to help basically teach
hospitality but actually what became
clear over time and if there's any
Airbnb people in the room who here who
know my time there a lot of what I
taught was emotional intelligence
it was EQ and leadership skills and what
I learned in return was DQ not Dairy
Queen but digital intelligence so the
trade agreement that was going on often
with me and the people around me and I
had over a hundred mentor mentees over
my six years at Airbnb has been often an
EQ for DQ to transfer now we can look at
my notes for one second
thank you for being patient with me you
know to actually give a speech the first
time in this venue is scary so the thing
that's interesting to me
in the world we live in especially here
in the Bay Area is we see young 20 year
olds starting companies that move to
being global Giants almost overnight and
somehow we expect these young digital
leaders to miraculously embody the
relationship wisdoms that we elders have
had decades to learn it's really hard to
microwave your emotional intelligence
and your leadership skills while I was
brought on to Airbnb supposedly to be
the knowledge expert around hospitality
what became clear to me pretty click
pretty quickly was that my fact
knowledge wasn't all that important let
me use an example one of the pieces of
fact knowledge that a hospitality
veteran would know is how many rooms
does a maid clean in an eight-hour shift
not all that important at Airbnb right I
mean most of our hosts I was in charge
of all the hosts globally they didn't
have maids they were doing the cleaning
themselves so that was a fact that
wasn't all that important but as my
young director number two in hospitality
team Laura Hughes who's 27 years old
said to me she said chip your fact
knowledge doesn't matter much here your
process knowledge matters a lot and I
asked her what do you mean she says you
know how to get things done you know how
in an organizational setting to get
things done because you understand the
underlying motivations of everybody in
the room and the people outside the room
that we need to go out and get things
done with you have in other words
organizational savvy and if you're
someone who's 25 or 27 and you've never
been in an organization of much size
that's something you don't know yes you
don't know the EQ stuff maybe that's
something that tends to build as you age
IQ doesn't EQ does so as I started to
and what was so fascinating is we
actually did well there's five
generations in the workplace today
although very few companies have five
generations in the company we did have
four generations in the company and
that's amazing to have four generations
in one company at the same time so we
better get better at intergenerational
collaboration
think of it almost like in an
intergenerational potluck because we all
have something to bring to the table so
while I was there at Airbnb in this role
I started to first of all not often but
sometimes people would make light of my
age generally it was fun one person
called me the elder and I was like
sounded like elderly I thought it was
that effect that's what they were saying
but you know there's a big difference
between being elderly in an elder in my
opinion we can maybe in Q&A talk about
that but here's the thing that Cate
became clear to me I started to see that
in a world where power is moving to the
young faster than ever before we've
never seen anything like this
organizationally
in terms of this increasing reliance on
DQ and it's not just the tech world it's
frankly 7 of the 10 most valuable
companies in the world today our tech
companies so every company wants to be a
tech company and everybody wants to hire
those digital natives who are going to
actually help them create a new strategy
for their company so when I started to
see was there's a new kind of elder
emerging in the workplace and maybe
there's a need for this new kind of
elder now this is not the elder of the
past who was regarded for their
reverence we know respect your elders or
Revere your elders know the this new
kind of modern elder that was being
created was was appreciated not for the
reverence but for their relevance their
ability to actually take their timeless
wisdom and apply it to modern-day
problems the ability to be as I was at
Airbnb both the curious student or
intern while also being the wise mentor
and I think a modern elder this modern
elder this new premise of a modern elder
which we'll talk about tonight is
exactly those towards it's all about
curiosity and wisdom curiosity opens up
possibilities wisdom distills those
possibilities into what's important and
essential
that combination of curiosity and wisdom
actually allows you to frankly be more
facile and able to be better able to
help distill down what's important
organization one of the things a lot of
us a lot of us know that as we get older
our brain isn't as fast as it used to be
nor do we have recall our memory starts
to actually fail a little bit one of
things a lot of people there's a lot of
societal in there items that don't give
credit to aging and so I'm gonna give
you one right here you know all of that
what you probably don't know is that the
aging brain gets a little bit smaller
with time and the thing that happens
with your brain is that you get older is
generally speaking you get
all-wheel-drive which basically means
you go you do the left brain right brain
tango better than a younger person now
probably not the real tank of a better
than younger person who knows maybe but
that you you actually are able to move
from linear to create creative much more
quickly more adeptly which means that
what is the result of that it means that
you get the gist of things faster you
could think systemically and
holistically much better than when you
were young when you were extremely
focused now in the context of an
organization like Airbnb that's growing
as fast as it is and has a lot of things
happening all over the world at once and
has a leadership team that's very young
to be the person in the room who can
occasionally synthesize and get the gist
of something and say I see pattern
recognition here and pattern recognition
is another way of saying wisdom and be
able to call that out is the value of a
modern elder in that workplace so that
led me to saying I wanted to write a
book so four years into Airbnb I left
day-to-day role and started I went down
to Mexico down to Baja California Sewer
about an hour north of Cabo San Lucas
and I decided I was going to go ahead
and start writing this book wisdom at
work the making of a modern elder now I
did a hundred fifty interviews while I
was this is like spring of 2007
so a little less than two years ago I
did 150 interviews with people in
midlife I initially defined midlife as
45 to 65 and it ultimately midlife
became 35 to 75 because I realized that
actually people do especially in Silicon
Valley start feeling a little bit
irrelevant and bewildered in their
mid-30s and there are a lot of people a
lot of people in this room who will work
way beyond the traditional retirement
age of 65 by choice or necessity so
midlife which was a crisis is now a
marathon I'm great news hardship so the
thing that was so interesting to me is
that no one had a roadmap for the second
half of life
I honestly the roadmap that people had
was this midlife crisis thing and after
the crisis oh you have decrepitude and
disease wow that's a lot to look forward
to so that's what I start saying like
thinking you know I was going to like
channel Ken Dyke well here what is this
middle essence thing adolescence was
this transitional period everybody
accepts that people in adolescence are
going through difficult times you sort
of cut some people some slack what if
middle essence is also a transitional
time it is a transitional time let's be
honest what happens in midlife
well you might change your job or career
or where you live you may get divorced
your parents may die you may go through
menopause men you'll go through
andropause check it on would compete
check it out on Wikipedia you're going
through some things you may if you have
kids you might have an empty nest
syndrome
you may have a health diagnosis that
comes out of left field all these things
happen and then like you get at age 50 a
few months a few weeks before you get
your [ __ ] AARP card I mean like
that's a transition for sure when you
didn't want Stuart I swear it's where is
that okay okay okay all right all right
so damn that's a lot of transitions
that's a lot of transitions but we as a
society act as if you're just supposed
to know it all in that period of life
and midlife you're supposed to know it
all well let's talk about this let's
unpack this a little bit I started
studying life stages as I was writing
the book I was like okay I'm writing
this book but now I'm like oh I want to
go learn about you know rites of passage
why do I want to learn about rites of
passage partly because I was thinking
this is weird
I think societies did a great job of
helping people go through transitional
times and create rituals rites of
passage celebrations so that society
supports people through those times so I
want to say what is a rite of passage so
what I learned is back about the time
when when G Stanley Hall wrote
adolescence this guy named Arnold van
Jeanette wrote a book about rites of
passage studying indigenous societies
and he said there were basically three
phases for a rites of passage there's
the first page which is the first phase
which is severence then there's the
second phase which is scary
it's the threshold or the liminality
it's that period when you're in between
two things liminal means to be betwixt
in between to be in a limbo to be sort
of in this awkward in-between space
puberty is that frankly when you're a
baby and you're learning to go from
crawling to walking that is liminal me
being up here giving a speech for the
first time to a group like this is
liminal because I should have you know
tried this out a few times first this is
the second phase threshold and
liminality and then there's this third
phase when you actually come back and
you're incorporated back into society so
the whole premise of a rite of passage
is you are severing something from the
past a period of time of your life often
that allows you to then go through a
difficult time and you come out on the
other side a new person does this sound
familiar if you are
who studied mythologist Joseph Campbell
you know it sounds very much like the
hero's journey that's where he got the
hero's journey premise was from the idea
of rites of passage and that's how
George Lucas created all the Star Wars
movies and lots of other Hollywood
people have used that idea of a rite of
passage as their model for those of you
who are saying that's way too abstract
let me give you some examples puberty
Bar Mitzvah Bat Mitzvah quinceanera the
commencement of adulthood graduation
ceremony and literally a commencement
you're gonna get married you have a
wedding you're gonna have a birth you
have a baby shower you die this is Bali
one of my favorite places you die and
you have a funeral but between baby
shower and funeral nada nothing why is
that it is because in the year 1900
longevity in the United States was 47
years old and it was a lot less than a
lot of other places some midlife as a
premise didn't make sense
midlife was 24 years 25 years old or
something like that so the thing is 1965
is the year that midlife crisis as a
phrase or it was coined that phrase was
coined by psychologists and it is now 54
years later from the boopa when we
coined that term and we've done very
little to solve it so that's part of
what I wanted to do which is why I now
consider myself at the crossing guard at
this intersection the intersection of no
longer and not yet which is how often
how we often feel in midlife so we
support people through adolescence and
we celebrate them but we don't do that
for middle essence no doubt about it and
then we can sort there's all kinds of
reasons like oh you know let's not
coddle the middle ages you know accept
to accept etc I can see what some of you
were saying right now but the thing I
want to just say is I think that we are
missing an off
frankly in the workplace because this is
a collection of people who more often
than not today feel like they're being
put out to pasture did you know that one
out of every four people ate in their
50s
lost their job between 2008 and 2013
that's why out there are a lot of
suicides that's why there's a lot of
opioid use in certain places where the
job situation is awful so I started
saying okay well good darn it let's
figure this out I want to figure it out
further so I'm gonna now go from this
rites of passage thing to try to
understand biology so the ultimate form
of liminality is this
so the caterpillar feasts on leaves
feast on leaves eats eats eats and then
one day the caterpillar actually
attaches itself to a twig or a branch
spins its own little cocoon which
becomes its chrysalis and out the other
side after a gooey mess if you've ever
seen the in between the stage the
liminal stage of caterpillar to
butterfly you'll see that it's just goo
on the other side becomes this butterfly
now you know I feel this is sort of like
you know first grade biology but isn't
it interesting that within the DNA or
within the the what the caterpillar had
it within it it had the capacity to
become a butterfly it's called these
imaginal discs so literally literally
the seeds of that caterpillar were I'm
sorry the seeds of the butterfly we're
within the caterpillar so that got me
thinking okay well how can we think
differently about midlife in this way
Carl Jung that's not Carl Jung but but
but this is a quite a famous quote of
his which I won't recite that speaks to
this idea that maybe it is that midlife
is a period when you're going into the
cocoon
maybe midlife is a chrysalis maybe
midlife is a liminal period what if it
was listen 115 years ago
G Stanley Hall taught us that
adolescence was still part of childhood
someone in 13 or 14 was not an adult yet
prior to that that's what they thought
that was an adult so maybe there's a
whole new thinking that we have to have
around midlife and beyond here's another
fact that isn't very well known so a lot
of society there's a lot of society
societal narratives they're at odds with
reality this is the U curve of happiness
how many of you have heard about this or
seen it before the beautiful book that
came out last year called the happiness
curve by Jonathan Roush I here's the
facts behind it in every country in the
world except Russia this is true in
Russia actually people get happier after
they die I said so there there's a cyst
there's a statistical error there I
can't I don't I don't understand it but
that's what I know
so we from about age 25 to about age 45
to 50 we go through a long slow slog of
our happiness gets lower and lower why
is that well it's the mash up of
everything first of all I think the
first half of life is about accumulating
the second half of life is about editing
so we accumulate like that caterpillar
eating leaves we accumulate we
accumulate stuff we accumulate
relationships we accumulate people we
date then we get married potentially and
then we maybe accumulate children I'm
gonna cue Malay trous Ponce abilities
jobs community responsibilities by our
mid 40s were worn out and we have way
too much on our plate and we just want
to go into a cocoon so I wish I'd seen
this when I was 47 years old and had my
really dark period and I wish some of my
friends are no longer with us I'd seen
this but and this is now actually quite
well known and what I will say is that
it's a narrative that needs to be better
known because it helps pee
to understand how to rejigger their
expectations one of the reasons things
get better and it's part that's bizarre
here I know for some of you thinking
like what really people in their 70s are
happier than their 60s happier than
their 50s happier in their 40s yes men
actually to be honest with you men
around 75 to 80 start to level off the
less last 5 to 5 to 7 years of people's
lives it's love as often then goes down
for physical health reasons usually for
women you know it goes all the way into
the early eighties so why does it get
better well there's a lot I mean read
Jonathan Roush this book it's a great
book but basically it's because we
rejigger our expectations if
disappointment equals expectations -
reality our expectations are high now at
some point our expectations end up
having to get changed that's part of
that liminal period that's difficult the
things we dreamed of we have to sort of
like say okay it's different now and you
start to actually get clearer with
wisdom of what's important getting down
to like the essence of what's important
so this is a very important thing for us
to know most of us don't know it the
other thing that's a lot of people don't
know is that as we get older we do know
that our EQ does grow it can grow with
time and we get better at just
regulating our emotions that's pretty
easy
I mean but the truth is the regulation
of emotions has a lot to do with
people's happiness all right so here's
chips weird transformational journey of
life graph let me take you through it
this is my premise of hell I think life
is meant to be but yeah this is the
first time you're seeing it because you
know it's probably idiotic but I like it
when we're young we have a growth
mindset that leads us to become an
emerging adult then we become this
embodied adult and we're eating down
those leaves like that damn caterpillar
and we have resources and skills and
experience all that's being dumped on us
then we have this cocoon period this
liminal period I'm gonna call it the
emerging Eldar period nobody wants to be
an elder when they grow up but guess
what I think it's going to
can't make a comeback it's a darker time
of life generally it says 45 to 65 it's
really probably more like 40 to 55 or so
and then we actually come out of the
cocoon we come out of that liminal
period we start to say to see what does
that say right there it says an embodied
elder and who knows you know maybe we
ultimately become an elderflower so the
idea elderflower that's was that was a
good joke um I also think as you get
older not only is it about the perfect
alchemy of curious and wise it's also
the perfect perfect alchemy of levity
and gravitas levity allows it to be
light gravitas is weighty and that
combination is to me the embodiment of
what it means to be an elder so I think
this has some possibilities now I'm no
academic I'm not a professor I haven't
written a book on this I've written one
article about it but actually when I
wrote the article about this stuff like
120,000 people read it and went sort of
like out there like okay maybe people
can actually see it and I like the fact
that when you turn it on its side it
sort of looks like a butterfly right
right yeah all right
so Richard Rohr is a Christian mystic
and he says there's much evidence on
several levels that there are two major
tasks to human life the first task is to
build a strong container or identity the
second half of life half is to find the
contents that the that container was
meant to hold you know the dominant the
trance of the dominant story or the
chance of the dominant culture the
societal story that we have is so at
odds with what it can be and what it is
for so many of us I think part of our
process in midlife is to move out of the
operating system of the ego sort of what
slomo talked about sort of move out of
the operating
system of the ego into the operating
system of the soul I think it's also
there's a beautiful Shakespeare quote
but also has been attributed to Picasso
by the way Picasso I was one of the best
quotes about technology I've ever loved
I've ever read
he Picasso said computers are useless
they only give you answers which an
elder is actually gives you a lot of
good questions hopefully so Shakespeare
supposedly said the meaning of life is
to find your gift that's the first half
of life the purpose of life is to give
it away that is the second half of life
and that is what an elder does so this
is literally where I live I live in Baja
I live there two thirds of the time now
this is Alfredo the cactus there are a
few people who hang out with Alfredo
right yes there you are so I went down
you know there's a beautiful quote from
William Blake that describes my
experience in Baja but I'm going to make
sure I don't get it wrong when I'm in
Baja I feel like I'm taking dictation
when I'm there in a very spacious place
somehow things start to channel through
me and that's why I get to a place where
I ended up writing the book but I also
started to ponder this question how are
we minting elders or how I minting
modern elders how are we creating this
space for people to reimagine and
repurpose themselves to mine their
mastery look at what they've gotten why
is that and then actually ask themselves
how they could apply it elsewhere and
how can they reframe their mindset
around aging in a world where the
societal narrative around aging is
pretty abrasive pretty pretty
problematic
so that led me to creating a place it's
called the modern Elder Academy you
would have read about it in this last
Sunday's New York Times but it was a
completely wrong article the article had
a lot of facts wrong on it but we can
talk about the ring during Q&A let me
start by just saying it is a social
enterprise I have spent my whole life up
to this point well I've been involved in
a lot of nonprofits and social
enterprises I've been a for-profit
entrepreneur out of even at Airbnb this
is a social enterprise I don't make a
dime on it I built the whole campus
three acre campus we give a million
dollars in scholarships away because the
a year because 50 to 60 percent of our
people are on scholarship because
frankly that investment banker at age 55
who's not trying to figure out what to
do with himself next he's got resources
to figure out to help help him but
there's a lot of people who don't have
those resources so people come they come
for a week 18 people in a cohort and the
real intent is to help them to become
more adaptable and resilient the goal of
doing this in creating this was really
to help catalyze a whole set of midlife
wisdom schools to be created around the
world I'm not going to create all those
I'm gonna create one this may be the
only one I ever ever create but I've
been lucky enough in my years the last
few years to be on the board of three
amazing organizations glide Memorial
Church here in the Tenderloin the Esalen
Institute down in Big Sur and Burning
Man so each one of those institutions
I've been on the you know on the boards
for each of those for about 10 years
each each of those institutions with a
single location catalyzed people
generally social entrepreneurs in a
nonprofit way to go out and create in
the case of glide progressively minded
churches doing good works in their
community in the case of esslyn ten
years after Michael Murphy and dick
price created esslyn they had a
gathering of personal growth retreat
centers here in San Francisco and a
hundred personal growth retreat centers
that show
all of them younger than Esalen so that
they catalyze something and then Burning
Man there's over a hundred festivals
transformational festivals around the
world that actually live by The Burning
Man ten principles so if you get it
right you can be a catalyst for others
to do something great so that those
rights have passed as we talked about
earlier
Arnold van jena p-- severance threshold
liminality incorporation well the way I
see it is this is how you become a
modern elder these are the four lessons
these were my four lessons at Airbnb
first of all I had to evolve
I had to strategically edit my
historical work identity and what I knew
and that's a hard thing to do that's
when for a lot of people in midlife
that's the hardest for me it meant
absolutely right sizing my ingo making
it smaller because I was no longer the
as I am right now the sage on the stage
I was the guide on the side I was the
guy behind the scenes helping the three
founders and their leadership team grow
the company but I was it was not me and
you know with on the marquee and that so
that required a lot of you know internal
you know rejiggering learning speaks my
favorite role model of all time in the
business world is again in Peter Drucker
he lived till age 95 and every two years
in his life I think part of the reason
he lived so long as he was so curious
he was always learning every two years
of his life he'd go study something new
that had nothing to do with being the
world's most famous management theorist
and he wrote two-thirds of his 40 books
that he wrote after age 65 so learning
is the elixir of life curiosity is the
elixir of life so that's the next thing
I had to learn Home Sharing I had to
learn millennial travel habits I had to
learn a lot of things thirdly it starts
to get a little easier
those first two are actually the hardest
lessons and and for those who want to
know more about this this is all in my
book collaborate here's the good news as
we get older we get better at
collaboration there's a lot of evidence
and and you know you I know you have a
cranky uncle that you're thinking about
right now that doesn't fit this but on
average
this is the case and why is it it's
partly because we have more empathy it's
partly because we're more moderate in
our emotions we know how to regulate our
emotions and it's partly because as
Google wanted out the number one common
a factor of successful teams at Google
was having psychological safety
generally speaking you created age
diverse team with at least a couple one
or two older people on the team they
create this space where it's not quite
as competitive and something comes out
of that which I call invisible
productivity an older person helps
everybody around them get better at what
they're doing and then finally you get
to counsel now for a lot of people who
want to be on modern elder they say I'm
gonna be the counselor and they come
across like the priest at the pulpit
you've got to listen to me I have all of
the knowledge and I'm going to just
dispense it to you sit down at my feet
no that doesn't work because then you
sound like a priest or parent and I can
tell you these young people don't want a
priest or a parent so what I realized
over time was my job was to be at times
the company librarian which meant I knew
that know how and know who I had a lot
of people I knew and I knew like I
didn't read a lot of books and a lot of
white papers and things like that and so
I would people come to me and they
wanted me to help transfer knowledge to
them and and make context for them
that's part of what I did as a counselor
the part of what I did as a counselor
also as I was as my director port Lisa
called me I was a confidante
now she's French my definition of
confident when she first said to me chip
you're my confidante
I said well you haven't told me anything
juicy yet I said true and she said well
in French we think of confidant as
you're the one who gives me confidence
you're my permission Arry you're the one
who gives me permission and you give me
the path for how I can get it done you
don't just you don't just sprinkle magic
dust on me you actually give me
confidence but then you also give me
guidance and you help me facilitate
awareness in Who I am
so
quick story I'm just good to this
briefly this is Carrie Henley on the
left and April her best friend from
childhood on the right they came to the
modern Elder Academy almost a year ago
this is a great story just because it's
so much about liminality Carrie showed
up and she had just moved out of her
home with her husband of 17 years so she
literally left her home Fort Collins
Colorado came to Baja to a week of the
modern Elder Academy and when she was
going to go back to Fort Collins
Colorado
she'd rented an apartment and she was
going back to rent an apartment so this
is very liminal she had also just
started a company called age Without
Borders and it was a company that
frankly didn't have any revenue coming
in and she was basically gonna be on her
own so she came and she was very
vulnerable she was in a place of
liminality a week later and you know I
wish she was here she can tell you
better than I could she was in a whole
different place
she had a new level of confidence a new
sense of how aging can be aspirational
and also a new sense frankly of her own
mastery what she'd the things that she
thought she had gotten good at over time
she had not she didn't even realize some
of the things that she had become a
master at and weirdly and this is not
what the program is about but um one of
the guys in the program yeah you know
yeah it didn't happen there it was
months later his name Steven this group
and many of our groups at the end of
their 18 people cohort they go off and
go back to wherever they're from and
we've had people from 16 different
countries and then they do a zoom call
in some cases every week some cases
monthly and Steven and Carrie just
started to build something and now they
are like like like that so we're not a
dating site I promise you better so
maybe midlife is meant to have a
pit-stop the way our our societal
narrative is that you fuel up between 18
and 25 with education and support
and then you're supposed to drive this
vehicle which is our body the rest of
our lives
and it's no wonder that in our 40s 50s
and 60s we feel like we're running on
fumes maybe we're supposed to have a
midlife atrium and a midlife pitstop so
we can actually imagine what's next for
us maybe it's maybe life is not a one
tank journey it's a two tank journey and
you're supposed to refuel here your
mileage may vary oh this is a beautiful
quote from Michael Meade mythologists
although an infant becomes a child
simply by aging a person cannot become
an elder by simply becoming older elders
fall into the category of things that
are made not born
becoming an elder is not a natural
occurrence the qualities needed don't
simply develop from physical changes
brought on by aging rather there is
something metaphysical involved
something philosophical and spiritual
that is required old age alone doesn't
make the elder one of my favorite
TEDTalks
I'm just wrapping up now for those
thinking like okay what's the timing
going on I see the clocks got is at its
end dan Gilbert wrote I did a TED talk
he did a few actually but one of his was
fascinating he said human beings are
works in progress that mistakenly think
they're finished every age group that
they looked at people vastly
underestimated what change was going to
happen in the next ten years every
single age group in other words life is
liminal it is constantly changing so
maybe like me you can start surfing or
maybe not the question is what is a way
for you to create your own rite of
passage what's the thing that you can do
or what can society do to start actually
celebrating people who in midlife and
Beyond choose to do something new
whether it's surfing or something else
there's a town near
earth Australia that actually has
something called the celebrant eval and
it's a multi-day festival celebrating
people 60 and older trying something new
in in in Japan that Kevin there's
something kind of can take Kentucky do
you know what it is okay it is I will
tell you what it is it is con Rican
Ricky and sixty years old is the
beginning of one's second childhood so
maybe it is time for us to imagine that
there is a period in midlife and Beyond
that's different so my thought on this
is I thought you know okay this all
sounds great and I'm gonna go write a
book and I'm gonna go out and be like
this missionary to go spread the message
and help the world see this and on the
second day of my book tour in September
I was in New York and I was at a TED
speaker's dinner because the very next
day I was giving a TED talk at Ted
headquarters and a TED salon and this
was six weeks before the modern Elder
Academy was gonna open to the public
after our beta period and I found out
for my doctor I had intermediate stage
prostate cancer
I got liminal I had a lump of my throat
because he'd said to me before I left to
go to Newark he said I think there's
only a 20% chance he was wrong
so life for me you know I'll be fine and
even prostate cancer is like you're
gonna get cancer as a man or anybody
it's like it's one of the better ones to
get but I'm pretty far along in terms of
how far along it is so I don't know how
I would have handled this maybe five
years ago and today knowing what I've
learned you know as the teacher one of
the teachers at the Academy and just
having studied what the fact that life
is full of transitions and life mid life
is full of liminality you know I'm
taking in stride and I'm learning that
you know I'll get through it and we'll
move on
I think it's time
for us to rethink the role of the elder
and to actually maybe even bring the
word back when you own a word it gives
you power for those who don't know that
the word Yankee back in colonial times
was considered a derogatory term it's
what the brits called The Dandy Yankees
testing their manhood and then the
Yankees the Yankee cut the colonists
owned it similarly in the 1950s if you
called someone black in the south it was
a slur and then Malcolm X and others
said black is beautiful and they owned
it if I was called a queer when I was on
the check-in in my childhood playground
it made me scared to hear that
but today LGBTQ community has owned the
word queer I think it's time for us to
own the word elder
so are you ripe awesome and ready to
blossom this is my last slide my last
thought and then Stuart's going to come
join me you know what the truth is do
the math do the math I talked about at
the start figure out how much of your
adult life what percentage of your adult
life is still ahead of you imagine
yourself both curious and wise how can
you create that powerful alchemy of
being curious and wise at the same time
how could you become a modern elder how
could you start embodying what are the
qualities of an elder in a society that
needs elders especially in the workplace
finally if you you know having talked to
some arborists about this in some
ecologist what we know about trees is
the following is that when you plant
young new trees near older mature trees
what the young trees learn is the
pathway of the root system and that
strong pathway of the root system that's
underneath a tree is the thing that
actually helps root those younger trees
and helps them to actually understand
how to be
come older trees and the forest and all
of us are better off for that because of
that underground connection so thank you
yeah lady name is Lee Leslie not sure
how do you say your last name Leslie
thank you I she says I recognize you're
not a woman but that you can talk about
women elders and whether their ideas
their situation differs from male elders
yeah so thank you
Leslie where are ya so great questions
to further just make sure everybody
heard that so when I first started using
the word elder I did have some pushback
from some women friends of mine saying
when I hear elder I think I hear I think
of church and I think of the male
members of the church were the elders
and that's not what we're meaning for
sure but let's also recognize that women
who are old or have the combustible the
combination of ageism and sexism
together men are debonair as they get
older women are not perceived that way
and so and there's all kinds of things I
talked I actually read about in the book
how women have it more difficult older
when they get older but here's the
interesting thing there's a study that I
talked about in the book where women
actually gain confidence with each
passing decade in the workplace by their
50s and even their early 60s they feel
smarter more confident and more embodied
as a leader whereas men actually start
to see a drop-off in their confidence in
about their mid-50s so I think what we
needed to see as a society is that women
come into their own
a little like men they come into their
own later in puberty right women tend to
exit girls tend to actually hit puberty
before boys a lot of times maybe in
midlife and especially in the
organizational setting women often
actually mature and become more
successful and more confident later in
their midlife working world but they
have to deal with that ageism and sexism
which is absolutely toxic
so at ashlynn a polite so for those who
want to actually understand someone
who's a big advocate on Ashton
Applewhite is she has a TED talk about
ageism but she also talks about sexism
as well this is nice there's a question
here we give the cell of their age Brian
age 34 asks can you share any learnings
you may have learned gleaned about how
to accumulate process knowledge as
opposed to fact knowledge and Kevin
Kelley has a related question is there a
modern young person and is there new
role for them to match your modern elder
well I think the modern young person has
been almost satirized
in in in TV shows like Silicon Valley
where the modern young person is this
hoodie wearing you know brash male
technologist and I don't think that is
necessarily what I can encounter at
Airbnb but there certainly is a sense a
lot of people I I get really frustrated
when I hear people beating up on
Millennials and saying oh they're so
entitled and there first of all they say
those of us are boomers when you talk
just be note notice this when you talk
about the Millennials and you and you
start saying four or five adjectives ask
yourself forty years ago if people would
have said that about you because a lot
of the issues around Millennials are
stage of life issues but there are some
specific things around Millennials that
are not stage of life issues the fact
that power has moved to young people
faster than ever before
means frankly they feel entitled because
they see Brian Chesky or they see you
know Mark Zuckerberg becoming
billionaires in their 20s so like I want
that too is it like how some of them
think so they get they get hard on
themselves so that's that question but
back to the question before it that
Brian asked and I don't think it's Brian
Chesky because Brian's 37 this one's 34
um how do you build process knowledge
process knowledge to my mind so fact
knowledge is just to recap fact
knowledge was like I you know the fact
that maids clean that certain number of
rooms an eight-hour shift is a fact
knowledge I brought to Airbnb that
didn't have any meaning the process
knowledge spoke to understanding how
you understand people and understand
people you can take psychology classes
or you can just be a person and a human
and be and be observant and you know at
the one things that's funny about the
movie the intern is Anne Hathaway didn't
want Robert DeNiro to be her intern and
what she said in the back of the car at
one point on his cellphone was he's a
little too observant being too observant
is what a modern elder is and the
question is if you're too observing it
means you actually observe and you have
pattern recognition about humans and you
have wisdom about how this movie is
going to end so to speak and I don't
mean the intern I just mean how things
are gonna go and so for the 34 year old
Brian how do you build that process
knowledge I would just say that the
thing I did in my early in my 20s and my
30s is every Friday afternoon for many
many years I don't do it anymore
that much but I still do it occasionally
I would write on Friday afternoon on
Saturday I would make a list for half an
hour of what I learned that week what
did I learn this week and I did it
particularly in times when I was really
struggling because it actually gave me a
sense of meaning there's no keep those
foolish to never look back I do that ya
know I still have the books and it was
called my wisdom book it was my first
time I was in book and then there was in
book second and a third and a fourth and
the thing that helped me do is it helped
me to understand I am learning some
things helped me to feel like okay I'm
embodying some wisdom along the way the
other thing is I'm a huge fan of
personality certain personality types a
typing test and there's something called
the Enneagram BNN EI gr am listen i've
learned it when I was 23 from a woman
named Helen Palmer in Berkeley and I got
to tell you my whole life has been
better by the fact I understand myself
and others a little bit better so
something I wondered is as you were
speaking and you're basically referring
a lot of things to your experience with
Airbnb but then you cut loose partly
from there to do your book and you did
all these interviews what surprised you
in the interviews what was new from them
well I you know after having read the
after having done my urban bee
experience written the book he started
the Academy then I sit down for an
interview and I was like oh I go face to
face with the ageism again it's like you
know I think the most strange question I
ever at was asked was have you used
Botox and I was like do I look like I
have I don't think so but no truthfully
and some European journalists asked me
he said you know I heard everybody in
Silicon Valley over 50 uses Botox and I
said I don't and I don't think that's
true and so ignore everything else
you've heard about so and though I mean
I think that I think that the the
narratives quite strong that somehow the
playing field that we're playing on is a
physical playing field so that means
like you know how you look how your ex
you know how you physically work out and
you know that if you're and we know a
lot of people and that there may be some
people here today and you're that's the
playing field you want to play on in
your 50s and your 60s your 70s and it's
impressive when you see these videos
these three minute videos of someone
who's just like you know bench-pressing
300 pounds at seventy-five years old but
in some ways I get sad when I see that
because I feel like they're playing on a
play I mean it's impressive what they're
doing but they're playing on the wrong
playing field and the the thing that
gets better as you age is your emotional
and spiritual depth and your ability to
then offer that to someone else and you
know the fact that you're the Freak who
can actually benchpress 300 pounds at 75
is okay but it's in some ways it's
almost like Arrested Development well it
was a good answer truly wonderful the
different reading that what I was asking
Thank You Stuart not the interviews now
so much as the interviews you did for
research for the book Oh
Queeny Airbnb in the book you talk to a
lot of people yeah what surprised you
from their perception their studies and
their accounts so I think the thing that
was most
and not surprising now that I think
about it but it was shocking at the time
was that word bewildered you at the very
start we had that quote from the the
West African writer and he says the you
know the adults are bewildered and
literally that is what I felt as I was
interviewing people people felt
bewildered because the narrative that
they grew up with about how they were
supposed to be in their 40s and 50s in
terms of you know hierarchy wasn't what
they're seeing and and they felt in many
ways like that you know powers moving 10
years younger and they're gonna live 10
years longer and so Wow 10 years younger
10 years longer 20 years of irrelevance
that you didn't used to have and so the
irrelevance egapp of that 20 years is
probably the number one thing I noticed
and people scratching their head of like
wow Silicon Valley is gonna figure out
how to help us live to a hundred but I
can't afford to live past age forty that
yeah so okay save brush your teeth learn
more languages all those things gonna
make things thrive for decades I'm gonna
get to the organization's Ryan Phelan s
you didn't reach out to Airbnb Airbnb
reached out to you and that raises the
question her question is how does this
kind of opportunity get to happen for
others two questions there one is how do
you get organizations reaching out like
that and is there role for your modern
elders to basically put themselves
forward and not wait to be asked how
does that play out
okay so Ryan's absolutely right my
situation was lucky and for all kinds of
reasons including the fact that the
company that actually tapped me on the
shoulder was a company that was like a
rocket ship and so all of that was lucky
and that was because I was a person who
had stature as a former CEO etc so long
story short is that was my benefit most
people don't have that so part of the
reason I have felt the sense of mission
to go out there and talk about this is
to help companies see that there's a lot
of value in
this intergenerational collaboration in
the workplace and and could they in fact
start to imagine modern elders within
the midst like google has a program
that's moderately well known with their
engineers where it's called twenty
percent time so the it's been like it
for a long time
engineers at Google who want to do
something entrepreneurial for the
company can apply to say they won't
apply twenty percent of their time to a
special project that their own
entrepreneurial project the is that
might actually turn into a product for
Google what if we created a modern elder
20% thing where there's somebody who's
been around for at least ten years in
the company understands the
institutional wisdom is what can would
have Ken called thirty years ago a
wisdom worker I think it's time to
retire the Peter Drucker knowledge
worker from sixty years ago because
knowledge is in our in our laptop and in
our phone but that wisdom is really here
and here so how do we help mint people
within our organization that already
exist and how do we change retirement
such that on Friday you're working a
hundred percent and on men that you're
working to zero percent that's nuts it's
nuts for companies it's nuts for people
and some people want that and if you
want it fine but if instead you'd like
to have a three year plan of sort of
your process of leaving you could create
almost like these wise elders in an
organization that's their job is to sort
of help institutionalize new people in
the company and after I wrote the book I
didn't even realize Procter and Gamble's
been doing this for decades they call
them the Masters mm-hmm and so that
program exists so I think it I think
what we have to do is get organizations
to see that and you know I think uber if
they could do it over again would have
had a modern elder next to Travis Travis
probably still have his job two CEO if
he'd had a modern elder next to him and
I I think that as we start to show
people that just because you're a
brilliant technologist doesn't mean
you've figured out life mmm-hmm and
often being a leader is understanding
life and interesting life is
understanding emotions and people and
humans and and that's the part that's
complicated sometimes in tech companies
so there's this thing in Silicon Valley
which we mentioned in the book of
the executive whisperer yeah the
executive coach and there's some
famously effective ones and that's in a
sense a kind of a tradition that's
accepted there is that as far as it goes
or is there more Verdi yeah I think you
know bill Campbell's the one I talk
about in the book who's passed away and
he's famously with Steve Jobs and a
variety of other people was there sort
of CEO whisper but the difference you
know what I think I would I'd love to
see that when you're a coach and that
kind of role you're not there all the
time and the value and having I mean now
that I've had my own personal experience
of it the value of being there all the
time is I'm able to intern publicly and
mentor privately and what that meant was
with Brian when I saw things that I
wanted to give him feedback on I've
never give it to him publicly and never
in the middle of the meeting that he's
running for me Brian you're doing that
wrong so but instead because I was there
all the time I had the opportunity to
give him feedback privately because I
was observing things along the way and
yeah so I think and the fact that there
were over 100 people who asked me to be
their mentor allowed me to understand
the organization more and those three
founders my god the company was growing
so fast so sometimes you get out of
touch with what's happening in the
organization so I was sort of wise Yoda
the people would come to and sort of
have conversations and I was helping
them personally
but I was actually in the process
learning things about what wasn't
working in the company which allowed me
to be helpful to these folks so I
actually think the traditional you know
executive coach who's talks with their
CEO twice a month that's there's value
in that but what I'm talking about
something sort of different than that so
Kevin Kelley raises the question do you
have a sense of what the ideal age
diversity profile in our organization is
like that's probably vary from industry
to industry but also the main raises the
question of besides that you're teaching
individuals how the transition go
through the liminal stuff to become the
next stage for themselves are you also
doing workshops for companies to help
them
transition into more age diversity in
their companies just starting to do that
so I'm not just starting to figure out
how to help companies have said a lot of
people have sort of said this modern
Elder Academy looks interesting we don't
want to do it as individuals we'd like
to come down as a group and do a private
thing where we could actually look at
how do we have better age diversity and
how do we value different voices so you
have millenials Gen Xers and and and
boomers altogether so we're starting to
do that mm-hmm um in terms of the ideal
mixture I think it does depend on the
the industry I think the more the more
at risk of disruption you are as an
industry the more you need a bunch of
young people in your organization and so
I think that I do believe that and so
and then if you're gonna go out and
disrupt an industry as Airbnb was I
think you need some older people from
that industry like me interesting who
could help you understand the landscape
understand the landscape I have seen a
handful of healthcare companies
healthcare startups here in the Bay Area
that are gonna go help they're gonna go
disrupt the healthcare industry and it's
a bunch of people 30 and younger who
don't understand the landscape of
healthcare mm-hm and you've got to
understand that because you can't just
come up with the great new product
that's gonna then change the healthcare
industry because you have to understand
the institutionalization of how things
are gonna change
and similarly you know one of the things
I said to Brian and Joe and Nate in the
first actually the first week I think
was we need to pay hotel taxes and
they're like what we're Home Sharing
we're not a hotel it's like if we're
gonna be a hospitality company we have
to pay hotel taxes and that was at a
time when we weren't we weren't paying
that yet and ultimately that was part of
where we got to and it was some of the
sense of like we are if we're gonna try
to be within the hospitality ecosystem
and we're gonna become as big as you
want this company to be which back then
six years ago was sort of laughable
because we were a tight we're a
relatively small company it's like this
this is the future I know my
pattern-recognition says to me we will
be paying hotel taxes someday let's
accelerate our process to getting there
so that's an example of where my
institutional
the industry was such that we would
never you know we that a lot of hotels
still fought us in fact in New York they
don't want to pay as to pay hotel taxes
because it amazes us but so that's just
a different this is very good advice and
it sounds like a different kind of
acquisition for companies that are
growing fast and typically sort of
acquire the the new range and skills
they want by acquiring companies that do
that which are often other young
companies yes and you're saying don't
just acquire companies acquire
individuals who have yeah the decades of
experience in the domain which they are
now expanding into there's a woman
Bridget Duffy who is here in the Bay
Area I don't know if she's Naviance here
but she's a doctor she was the chief
experience officer at the Cleveland
Clinic she works with a bunch of young
Millennials now who are disrupting
health care but her role is to not just
sort of lay out the landscape and say
this is how a disruption will occur if
it happens but also to make
introductions to people within the
industry and within the government
because that just you know any kind of
disruptive technology is gonna have to
figure out how to work within the
landscape as well as the regulatory
landscape as well and sometimes it's the
older person who has been there that
actually can make the introductions so
you hire people for whom the term is
their rolodex
yeah exactly what are the people who
might barrel when you say rolodex to a
millennial they say what's a rolodex and
that's that's the generational but I
also wonder if there's you know we keep
having to relearn that diversity health
and diversity in various work groups
helps and male and female and different
races and different backgrounds and
you're saying in different ages but how
is age diversity different from these
other kinds of other cities so you great
point so I think diversity has gotten a
lot of great you know now empirical
evidence that shows that it generally
works in groups especially in
organizations and companies but here's
the fascinating piece of it for
companies that have a diversity and
inclusion program globally only 8% of
them have expanded that beyond gender
race sexual orientation and whatever
else to include age so age is not often
thought of in the diversity realm how
it's different want it to be I think I
absolutely want it to be and I think one
element of it is you know cognitive
diversity which sometimes can be neuro
how your how your brain works but also
cognitive diversity speaks to what your
experience in life is and so I actually
think one of the beauties and one of the
a few Europe has done a lot more testing
and and Studies on age diversity than
the US has interestingly partly because
Europe is aging faster in places like
Germany in fact actually had to do this
what they've actually been able to show
is that age diversity has a particularly
interesting phenomena relative to race
or gender diversity in that gender
diversity means a more better
collaborative skills for sure but what
age diversity offers is more synthetic
thinking more what I talked about
earlier that ability to get the gist of
something and not to move too quickly so
what they showed in a major German study
was a young team all by itself all by
itself makes decisions quickly and makes
a lot of mistakes an older team just
older people takes a long time and makes
fewer mistakes when you mix them
together you get the best of both worlds
and that's what age diversity can offer
the the organizational world brilliant
thank you yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]